you want to do my next video
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hop boxing with mike tyson i
am your co-host
henry sudo aka triple c and i'm mike
tyson
baddest man on the [ __ ] planet
and today we have a special guest
gee easy
man what's up with it talk to us
hey man i'm happy to be here i'm
grateful you know it's my first
time meeting you this is my first time
meeting you yeah that's crazy
that's my first time thank you for
coming with me that's
you know that's pretty that's what
they've been saying you know to talk to
me man how do you get started in this
business
i started i started rapping about 17
years ago really
uh just just made you want to do it i
mean growing up in the bay and i was
just
you know the culture i'm surrounded by
and you know and uh
you know i was just i gravitated to
hip-hop you know from just being
surrounded by it but
it was around the time when um when you
know you could actually like
you could get a cheap microphone and and
and myspace had just come out
you know i'm in high school people i was
growing up with um
it was a group called the pack they had
a song called vans
like got my vans on but they look like
sneakers got my fans out of those things
they're talking about
yeah yeah but anyway so you know it was
it was like we were in high school and
recording songs at home making beats you
know what i mean and uploading it to
myspace and
you know that idea that you could like
make music
you know record it release it you know i
mean and potentially get on
and i mean it was was all brand new
prior to that you would have had to be
signed and get into a bigger
memo yeah but you could just do it at
home
so i went to high school with them and
when that song blew up they got signed
and it was like it felt like
one week i'm sitting next to you in
class the next week you're on mtv
you know in bt and it was like damn like
we could really do this
it was like a possibility and i just i
never felt out of luck
you have a group who you basically sold
at the time yeah at the time
it was like a group thing kind of um
and then i uh i just you know eventually
went solo and i just
you know i never felt out of love with
it and i you know just been in love with
the process ever since
it didn't come it didn't come quick
it's an exciting journey too right yeah
these guys it was
yeah it was who was who was on the group
yeah and in the beginning
i mean it was just me and me and my
homies like
everybody had to be a rapper
but i'm you know i'm still i'm still
close with uh with a few of them but
that was just it was like a dream it was
like a you know but i always
i always took it really seriously you
know i was like something in me
had this like obsessive maniacal drive
to like no i really
like can be this i just believed it and
i wouldn't let anything [ __ ] stop me
i just
really [ __ ] wanted it and and at the
time i probably
looked and sounded crazy because the
music was horrible
like horrible like trash and just
learning how to like
find my voice learning song structure
how to count bars how to
you know how to really produce music and
um
but like i always tell people man if
it's a labor of love it's like
if you love something inside and out
you're gonna do it a lot because you
love it and if you do it a lot you
eventually get better at it and you get
better at it you you
improve
you know iconic and timely michael
jackson i want to be like michael tyson
yeah you know now but like you know i i
i'm inspired by
the use of the world like people that
transcend their spaces
a lot of your music is based on like
you're pretty much you're he's
you know he writes about his experiences
yeah
i think hip-hop naturally is just
autobiographical you know
in its nature it's like you're telling
stories of
you know from your perspective and all
that um
but you know again like like getting
back to this i think um
you know i am inspired by you know
people are different walks of life
different
spaces different you know whether it's
whether it's all right yeah
there's a commonality you know among
people who want to be great
people who take things seriously and
people who really have that drive and
that push
and i see that you know i mean like the
way
you know you've had these different
phases of your life and career
and i mean the the space you're in right
now
maybe even the best you know something
you know that's crazy
i always noticed this well i don't know
if i noticed this but um
i always lived by this theory um
i've met a lot of great men but not many
of the great men i met were good men
yeah so i tried hard in my life to try
to be a good man i'm not saying i
am but that's my goal in life to try to
be a good man
you strike me as a good man well i try
to be honest i haven't just met you but
honestly i tried hard and i still
haven't had i have characteristics about
myself
of course yeah and there's and there's
things that i've i
feel the same way and it's it's a
challenge especially right and and
but you know in any level of like
limelight spotlight entertainment
you know you have a lot of things thrown
at you and you have to you know you
carry a lot of weight and
and you know you provide for a lot of
people and you know you have a lot of
things being i don't have
something though what do you say we
provide for a lot of people we don't
feel as if we work then they we can't
find somebody to provide for them
yeah we have to be able to take care of
subconsciously our mind we have to take
care of somebody
yeah he doesn't there's a weight but
that's
you know that's that's what you're
conditioned and built for
yes exactly you know what i'm saying and
i mean you're you know you're built
different
yeah there's a there's a higher calling
and and
you know of course it can get
challenging and exhausting at times bro
because it's like
you got a different responsibility than
some you know how's your situation
since the pandemic been going i've been
shot with johnson and johnson
yeah i i got my first shot at moderna
my second one in like a week or two but
it's it's been a challenge because
listen like every industry was impacted
differently some industries
you know did well in a pandemic some
exactly
it hurt so i always keep my perspective
of
you know i'm grateful that i have like a
passive income through music and
streaming and [ __ ] but
touring i miss being in front of people
man it's not a job to me it's my life
it's my purpose
you know it's performing and connecting
with people and not being able to
congratulate
i'm grateful i was grateful for my home
that i live in i never really got to
spend time in it i lived out of a
suitcase you know you're always
traveling shows
appearances and i have a studio in it
but it made me think about
like kids and and you know people in
relationships that
every home is not a safe home to stay
inside of you know when they were doing
mandatory lockdown and stuff like that
think about
you know that just it just i kept that
perspective
of gratitude of like you know
considering what it's like for other
people and what they're going through
you know and just yeah because you had a
pretty big uh tough up
you know you grew up in oakland right
yeah talk about a little bit about your
uh your upper and your childhood a
little bit
uh bounced around a lot my parents split
when i was little
um and moved into my grandparents home
with my mom and brother sharing a room
truthfully bro i like i found myself in
music
you know that was like my in my safe
place my like
you know my passion my like you know
place to
to really like feel comfortable in
myself and
at you know at peace like and and i
think my mom
probably supported it because it was
like at least they're inside and they're
not
you know like all my homies would come
over after school and we'd be in my
little room
at the time like where i had my little
setup you know recording trying to make
work on songs and
she's like well at least they're not
outside getting in trouble when did you
get that feeling when you know and we
all happened
yeah it's not about being unhumble when
you knew you were different
yeah i was listening and i was i was on
the amtrak training to go visit my dad
um and i was listening to the black
album jay-z looking out the window
and back when you had to buy cds and you
could only you know
if you had 15 bucks you had to pick one
cd at the
you know i mean at the tower records or
whatever and i i played that album
front to back up and down so many times
still my favorite hove album
but i was like you know and it sounds
foolish
you know because it sounds foolish but i
i just i i like i heard
his listening to his voice i was like i
just i i want to be him
like period him and i'll stop at nothing
like
i was like i would chase i would chase
this and nothing under it
that feeling and and and that like that
never
once that locked in me it never unlocked
you know
and that's that the grit don't clip man
like
it was just that drive never you know
stopped
it's the inspiration right inspiration
that mike took it from somebody
yeah yeah it's like speaking about that
what do you
the whole thing with dmx did you yeah
you know so
dmx man it impacted me heavily
have you met him yeah i brought him out
at a show in new york i did
and um this was
four or five years ago now yeah and um i
had flown my mom out for the show
i i don't think i got to holler at him
until after the concert
uh but my mom after the show told me
she was walking backstage and he was
walking backstage
and they they met in the hallway
and he like i don't know if he would
have recognized her as my mom
or if she necessarily would have
reckoned i'm sure she recognized him as
dmx but like
it he just broke down in tears and
hugged her and they had this
this like spiritual energy moment and
like
he like he he said something that night
and it's crazy because you said
something really similar on
on one of your podcasts i think was the
bill berwin um
about you only succeed when you can help
others succeed
yeah dmx said almost the same thing that
night
and it stuck with me and he was like
you know my purpose is to inspire and if
i can do that then i was here for a good
reason
and you know his energy my mom is
is a big energy type person i mean she
describes this one time she got to
listen to the dalai lama speak
and she felt this like like astral
projection energy from him that you know
it may hit her and
and you literally like you have that
kind of spirit and i could already feel
it you know what i mean
and like and x had that
like just this this this power and this
presence and this purity and his energy
and obviously he fought his his demons
and he had his battles and he had
you know all his struggles and you know
but
he had this like this this presence of
positivity
and clarity that was just really like
profound
did you know him too mike did you have a
good relationship with you no no no
i met him i guess they were um they were
in phoenix one time and he was with this
uh he was with some little chicken i
knew our uncle
we used to pick pocket together yeah
and um it was in the same room when they
went to
any um i was on cocaine so the [ __ ] was
talking really um
he was talking studious so i thought
this [ __ ] yeah
he's not yeah so you could feel cocaine
so i look at this [ __ ] how he rap he's
a grimy [ __ ] yeah
so i meet him he's stuck in studios
i'm like i said this [ __ ] [ __ ] with
me
you know i'm thinking he's [ __ ]
that's not my money this [ __ ] [ __ ]
with me why is he talking like that
yeah and he was very studious and
articulate he was very i think then he
was diagnosed and wise
i'm like cocaine that [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] talking like that that's
that coke paranoia that's that coke
paranoid
oh man
he was so striking for that reason of
like you know
like he was he was so articulate and
if you never met this guy you would
think this guy would be the most fantasy
you would think he's a beast a savage
right
and then you start talking are you
[ __ ] with me man
yeah yeah no it was not an act and
that's really who he was bro
and like and i just remember just being
so same way kind of just like
surprised but pleasantly surprised
obviously because it was just like wow
this is a person you would never think
of
talking like this kid so so loving
and so positive he was just like he kept
saying thank you
you know thank you i love this like i'm
so happy to be here
man you know there's people out there
that love everybody but themselves
yeah they're out there millions of them
they don't know how the
um like selfish people interjected to
themselves they don't know how to do
that
yeah i mean self love self care all that
you know is is obviously that
it's at a forefront right now and it's a
conversation and mental health and all
this is going on
and it is tricky though man and it's
like and
uh there's also a crazy dichotomy
sometimes of um
highly successful people and i've heard
you talk about this too is like
um on one hand that self-doubt
and that feelings of inadequacy and you
know i'm not good enough or
i'm afraid of ever going back to
something i came from the of of that
place of inspiring people that inspires
you and then on one hand you could feel
like
all the confidence of a god and then on
the other hand feel like yeah
i'm not [ __ ] and my insecurities are
eating me with a little self-worth
right that sounds like that sounds like
you're talking well that's a lot of
that's a lot of the most the most
successful people are that way
yeah you know they think they're gone
but really they have
low self-worth it's crazy it's crazy
well i mean there's like there's a never
satisfiedness
you know i think it comes from poverty
yeah
and scared of going back yeah um and and
the hasn't have nots you know i mean
like i remember
like i mean my shoes were from goodwill
and i really wanted jordan's
you know what i mean and and and when
you get made fun of for something that
you don't have or that you
you know you wish you were that kid or
something like that that places
something in you of like this like
constant like i'm comparing myself to
something else or i'm wanting to
you know i mean to to be something that
i wish i had or something
that's like all like that yeah and then
and then once you finally get it
that we don't have you know and if you
drive if you're lucky enough like if you
if your drive
pushes you and you and you achieve this
kind of success i think in the back of
your mind
you're always kind of paranoid and
scared of losing it
because it is so fragile right i mean
yeah but the reality is um
he don't know i guess it was milton
berle and those guys
and george burns i had lost buster
douglas in 1990 and i was disappointed
i said man i really answered i really
failed didn't i he's a fail
yeah you crazy you make 30 million
dollars you fail
yeah but you're hard on yourself bro i
think it's cool with the similarity
would you agree mike that there's
similarities to like you know because us
has fighters we fight
we have a big fight it's kind of like
our okay it's hard like our one hit
you know kind of like it would be in
music yeah so there's a lot of parallels
more than that because i keep the
attitude in my life
yeah the way i fight it that's the way i
live my life
yeah i'm reckless but totally confident
and supreme
i think i think anything competitive is
music is very competitive
you know is like kind of like all eyes
on you it's like all right show us
perform
you know it's like if you guys you know
i mean you have this big fight and it's
like all right all eyes on you perform
go out there deliver
that's why a lot of entertainers
athletes are not um
happy people no matter how much they get
because they continue to compare
yeah and to compare is like the the
thief of joy but it's like
it's just definitely the fifa joy that's
a good lesson man this is this is this
is dalai lama
this is dalai lama again man he's really
full of games
he's really full of some games if you're
not in your bed
in your corner at the middle of the
night they can go right making you a
guard
you're a weird [ __ ]
no thanking god for making you a god
yeah
you could have been anybody else you're
just somebody's happy nut yeah
you know life is so beautiful man it's a
lot it's a lot to be grateful for
it's a lot to be grateful for man look
i'm i'm sitting here i'm i'm
you know i'm sitting next to y'all you
know you know
yeah no you got married all you no
you'll get another 100 million [ __ ]
higher number higher number go up no
listen don't go too high baby the left i
don't know i need a higher number
better know what we got 2.5 we had got
two points
what tell us what happened man 2.5
million [ __ ] billion hits
oh oh i thought you said that it's me
it's from doing this
but you man you you transcended you know
and i think that's what that's what
icons can do is transcend their space
you you complete the transcendence
there's like there's two or three of you
in your field that have ever walked this
earth
you know what i mean that i i think in
terms of cultural
like impact you know i mean like you're
jordan and you're at tiger woods yeah
you know you think that i don't think
that i that's not my success my sister
is not going to prison yeah you know
yeah not having another baby on my wife
or something stupid like that yeah
that success me yeah but this fighting
[ __ ] that's just hard work
that's what i'm born to do yeah i love
it
are you gonna fight again absolutely
[ __ ] right [ __ ] right
you know it's crazy okay so you know in
rap
we're starting to see you know because
it's it's really not that old
you know you got people like i remember
the first song i was locked up and
chilling out detention and rapid delight
came on it's like
79. that's crazy is that rapid delight
yeah so you so you so you're seeing
like like you know like our
you know rogs our legends the jay z's
the e40s the people that have been in it
this long the nazis yeah i mean like
people
like m like you know i mean who've given
us so much for so long and
and you know they're like they're up
there in age but they're still killing
it like e40 is as sharp as he ever was
yesterday
i mean there's no such thing as age it's
all about it but the thing is it's like
creativity i don't think if you're if
you're an artist
it's very hard to think about retiring
because it's like well i just don't know
what else to do
athletes and some in some cases it's
like your body just tells you i can't do
this
anymore yeah but tell us a little bit
about that energy mic did you just
mention
well you i mean your body's not telling
you to retire you still you're still
sharp
cause um you almost broke my hand when
you got me off but i mean you still got
your
hands iron mike it's just that i want to
be up more than anybody in the world
wants me to be down
yeah this is this is like you say this
is competition this is why
happiness is hard everybody you know
you're fighting these evil elements as
well
yeah i know you know that i got chills
he's just dropping gang got to fight
these elements [ __ ]
yeah yeah you got to take a deep breath
[Laughter]
all right you know what he pulls he
pulls him heart strings
you know what i love you know what i
love it feels i love
one of the greatest things about like
like achieving anything is
is the chance to kind of like you know
to either get to work with or meet or to
talk to
you know the the people that
you know inspire me are are legendary
and are
goats in in their respective spaces
because there's that commonality but
when you see a goat do some goat [ __ ]
yeah i mean you really see a legend do
some legend [ __ ] and it's not about
necessarily just their sport i i mean it
in the sense of
our my friends and how we're built and
and the way we approach life and things
you know like i got to i got to shoot my
arm cover yesterday with nabil
legendary photographer and it was crazy
like watching a goat do goat [ __ ]
i mean like i'm looking back at the at
the shots and he's he's crazy the way he
uses light
and i'm looking at him like [ __ ] you're
really that guy like [ __ ] like you know
what i mean like
like you're doing a song with chris and
i'm like you know what i mean it's 10
cut vocals and like
back and i'm like you're really chris
like you really do this yeah
and absolutely so it's like getting to
dance with a legend and like they you
know i mean like
they really do what they do and it was
like you know it's it's fine because
i probably struggle with this for
a long time is this feeling like [ __ ] i
belong too
i i belong at this table you know and
that's that
that that that fear of inadequacy are
not good enough or whatever like that's
driven me most of my life or being an
outsider
or misunderstood or whatever but it's
like you know
i'm i'm coming to a place where it's
like well no but like
i mean you belong here too gerald like
stand up yeah i mean
exactly yeah you know um you have to you
have to
believe that if you only this is a
competitive field like this
you know you know this is what we do
yeah
want to be the best in this field we're
not the best with nothing
number two is nothing we don't see them
see you
losers in our mind see number two
they make these names up but loses this
name just to inspire our ego
even after a loss mike how did how did
you how would you view
maybe like a loss i would never take it
personal
even though it's very difficult i'll be
very um
objective about it and then i'll look at
my mistakes i'll
constantly watch my mistakes and it's
probably similarity probably i imagine
in your guys's industry too right you
guys sometimes you guys get knocked down
just like
that as big as what is like man there's
this control and chaos right there's
certain things you can control and i you
know i mean
like like i know that your sport
is you know it's a it's chess it's a
thinking man's
sport you know no one ever said that
yeah see they think it's a tough guy
yeah yeah i know tough guys go talk
funny at the end of the day and this is
yeah this is the thinking guy
sport yeah now you you you have a
precision
and a you know and a knowledge of it and
you know of of a master level obviously
you know i mean like i said
one of like three that's never walked
this earth this is good at it you know
what i mean
and at that level of like brilliance
your mastery
at the end of the day and all this
matter can only control the elements you
can control
there's certain i mean the other guy you
know i mean he's gonna do what he's
you know what i mean you can you can
anticipate
you know the the you know the the
certain aspects i would imagine of it
you know what i mean but at the end of
the day you can only control what you
can control
as good as well only a percentage of
that you can control that's what i mean
so it's like [ __ ] i mean i could you
know i could i could do
all the the the promo i could i could
have the best mixing engineer mix the
song
i could you know i mean like i could i
could i could be in my best space
writing it you know i mean i can have
the best producer produce it
you know what i mean and you could do
all those things you can't control you
put the song out shit's just not a hit
like certain things you can't or it
doesn't the timing don't work out or you
know i mean
you can't just say orange just ain't
that good sometimes maybe sometimes that
[ __ ] is
like you know what i'm saying like um
like sometimes you don't train as good
as you should and you're going there
you're still knocking
that's what yeah that's exactly what i'm
saying right i should have trained
harder
yeah sometimes when you think a
combination works next you're not what
the hell
i'm on the floor on the campus just
holding this guy
the one thing you can't always do you
can you can give it your all
like doing the [ __ ] you can't control it
so that's you know
our our culture and work ethic you know
with
something can go wrong it will yeah but
it's what we do after it goes wrong
yeah you go to plan b and we stay
determined and disciplined
yeah you know and off on what discipline
what i was taught discipline was doing
something that you hate
but doing it like you love it yeah
i know you don't want to be in those
studios all the time when you see when
there's something else going on
yeah the one being that sweaty nasty gym
the mother sweaty nasty [ __ ]
with that
that when there's a lot of stuff going
on outside
sacrifice that yeah it's a higher
calling but then you see
you recognize but then you see on the
flip side too mike that people even that
work so hard sometimes don't make it
and the same thing in his industry it's
like sometimes they have sometimes it's
you know how much you rely on ability
but listen right
yeah it's dumb it's just the prize and
the rate
it's worth giving your life for
absolutely and
and i mean i was never the most like
just
naturally gifted or talented or anything
like that i just work the hardest but
you know like when kids ask me like what
advice do you have for upcoming artists
or something like that
and the same thing i always say is just
like do it for the right reasons do it
because you love it
like i was lucky enough to find what i
love in life some people don't
but you know people get so bent on the
reward instead of the process and it's
like if you're innocent
just to try to get rich or famous or
make it or whatever you call that
then you're in it for the wrong reasons
but if you do it because you love it
then
almost that should be enough i mean not
to say you know what i mean but it's
like do it because you love it
that makes you happy i can't explain
what time for young men
you know whatever it may be your name is
still there
yeah that's what all this [ __ ] about
i'm telling you it's like we looked at
the guy before us yeah
yeah there's a there's a legacy
there's there's legacy becomes legend
and all that but it's
it's like what you said was which was so
exactly similar to what dmx had just
said
was you know essentially
what you can inspire others i want to
hear a legendary vegas story from the
vegas years the wildest like craziest
like listen um
you just name it when i was fighting the
vic you his name
yeah i was like i was listening i'll
praise the guard up i was treating like
a car when i was like yeah
yeah listen what i was doing back it was
just
it's just ridiculous ridiculous
stupid you know that's how i know i'm a
fool and guard
fool because i'm ridiculous but in the
wild days i'm sure like a tuesday
afternoon is probably what
[Music]
they give you these big houses for these
training camps you know you stay at
these big beautiful but you wouldn't
would you you wouldn't be partying like
when you're
when you're training well that's later
in life after the
yeah that was late enough as i got older
but i was would you party big after a
win
yeah yeah
because it was legal yeah i couldn't
afford to have a dirty test
i only smoked twice man isn't it crazy
how weed has changed
i remember my mom she had to hide it for
me
you know when i was in high school and
growing up and i was hiding it from her
but but to the point now that you know i
mean like
like i partnered with a company i'm
building my brand um
flower shop and you know but it's like
it's it's so
and this beautiful thing you know how
acceptable it is and how
you know well have you have you have you
had some tyson ranch what's up mike
you want to baptize a mike brother as
always
you're welcome brother thank you
whatever you want brother hang out with
us
no no take one of these brothers that's
what i smoke
we have the lighter yes there we go
right there typing right
so you're in the cannabis business too
then you said flower shop
yeah right i wanted to kind of just cup
twice two-time champ
yeah you're killing it i love what
you're doing
see i really want to um in the next kind
of like
you know phase of my life and career and
obviously
the entrepreneurial [ __ ] and launching
you know in this space
but i really want to act really yeah
like i've always wanted to be in movies
as much as that oh you would kill these
mothers yeah you could tell me you could
tell
by the music video you're you know what
i'm saying
right yeah yeah you look you're
bay is a unique place man it's a special
place it's it's a place of
paradise but a lot of counter culture
you know what i'm saying like think
about the history of the bay from hugh i
mean black
they started the really the revolution
hippies you know i mean to the hyphy
movement is what i grew up on
in the mid 2000s which was you know this
like crazy wild just time you know
era are you are you fan of any like up
in newcomers
like you know because the industry has
changed a lot it seems like guys are
just popping up like left and right
black [ __ ] with brave teeth
the father
yeah no kitty man man but yeah i'm
releasing my album
uh it's been the longest time
in between albums in between albums that
i've ever had in my career and kovic
kind of [ __ ] that up for me
you know because i'm used to just living
on the road like living on the road
like like [ __ ] 200 shows a year 250
shows a year
type [ __ ] so you know i want to be able
to release that and then go come to your
audience how big is your reading
a lot of people yeah yeah the biggest
show i ever did
i sold out this amphitheater in the bay
was 23 000 people yeah
and just seeing a sea of people like
that you know
it's fine like it's it's just like
there's no way to explain it like
being on stage and you know you're in
front of the sea of people that share
this one
commonality of like they all enjoy this
music
and it's the [ __ ] that i make and you
know
not all some like you know need to be
worshipped or looked at that way or
anything but it's just like that gives
me purpose and fulfillment of like
i wrote this song alone in the studio i
released it
and now it gets to come to life with the
people who it means something to
like in the moment you know i mean it
was always about the people with me
was eminem another big uh influence
absolutely yeah absolutely man
who who's going mountain for you bro i
mean eminem
lil wayne jay-z you got you got four
you got oh i got four nah nah i can't i
can't do that i can't do the four i
give you ten because i gotta i gotta say
e40 mac dre
the vicious i know they are nas
jadakiss yeah jada kisses yeah
kanye big i mean drake big l yeah big
girl was nasty yeah [ __ ]
yeah i'm so ahead of my time that my
parents haven't met yet
he's a bad kid in the streets yeah yeah
rest in peace
he's a bad kid it's so it man you can't
pick
four or five because it's also so much
different like criterias and yeah i mean
because snoop is
you know like hey man it's yeah it's
really hard to
to narrow that down if you had to pick
five what's your top five
probably little wayne i like i like
jay-z
kanye and probably uh i like jada
kissman really he's in your boy i love
that
so i moved to new orleans 2007.
um i went to college uh
down there um and
i was i was a huge little weighing fan
at the time this was like mixtape wheezy
going in the car to three he hadn't
released it yet
i get to new orleans and it was just
like you couldn't walk a block without
hearing weighing out of some car
it was like there was so much love for
him everywhere in the world at that time
especially but in his city
that [ __ ] was so inspiring to see man
he's a bad man and then when carter
three dropped it was like
i mean he was completely out of here
like it was like he
he launched into the super stardom level
and
took it to arenas i remember that you
know i mean he was touring his ass off
and uh my roommate at the time who's
still my manager to this day
my roommate in college we're each paying
275 bucks
a month for our rooms in this apartment
a city apartment
and he interned for a festival voodoo
fest in new orleans and lil wayne was
headlining that year
and he randomly got assigned to their
camp and he's helping him out
you know and i'm watching from the crowd
i'm you know
i'm just like damn my roommates back
there with wayne that's crazy
a couple months later wayne's going on
tour and he gets a call
from the tour manager say hey you want
to come on the road with us and be
my assistant and i'm like
like damn bro you're really about to
like do a tour no he
this was him and he did it yeah and he
was getting paid i think like a thousand
dollars a week or something so he
instantly became our richest and coolest
homie like
he's on the lane you know i mean like
the biggest artist in the world
and then i remember one day i'm getting
food in the cafeteria or something
and he calls me he said there's this kid
on the young money bus
that i've been smoking with and kicking
with every day and his music is crazy
you got to listen to it
and he i was like send me the link and
it was myspace.com
drake or something like you know and him
and drake had a bond and they've worked
together ever since too
you know just like that man i remember
when i was like when i went
i hung out with him on tour one time he
never said a word he'd be so quiet who's
that little waiter
he's what's up big mike and that's
awesome so so eventually
fast forward like you know it wasn't
until like
six years seven years after that and i'm
i'm pop like i'm getting my [ __ ] going
on my own now i was
independently touring like out of my
other manager's girlfriend's parents car
that they lent us
you know i mean and we're playing in
front of like 10 people 20 people
barely giving gas money to the next city
i turned that into okay we come back and
then it's 100 people next time and then
it's 500 people next time then it's a
thousand then it's you're selling it
away only hard times can be yeah yeah
you know so then so then after i'm
finally getting my ball rolling
like i get asked to go on tour with
luanne and now i'm opening up but i'm
back to the bottom of the bill
i'm first to six on that tour there's a
whole amphitheater of people and it's
like
you know 100 people in by the time i go
on stage and they're walking around
trying to find their seats
you know i mean i don't think wayne even
knew i was on that tour like i would
never see him
like enigmas he's on his bus working
all day he would walk from his bus to
stage and then go back to his bus and
get back to work
man so many things to be grateful for
right guys yeah just to wake up not many
people didn't wake up this morning how
many people not gonna finish tonight
yeah yeah could be one of us you never
know
but while we're here and how many people
don't get to talk to mike tyson
well listen man it's about youtube
brother
yeah you make these people that's not
aware of me aware of me
yeah that's what's up man next time i'm
gonna make this big enough where you
could perform here
oh yeah i'm gonna have what bands could
perform me i'm gonna have a band yes
yeah that'd be awesome for the show yeah
that'd be great like at the end of uh
you know i'm saying at the end of like a
late night tv they always got a
performer and [ __ ]
big bad snail type [ __ ] yeah i was like
yes you know but like
yeah nah but think about that like that
that would be like the
highly coveted sought after like damn if
you get to perform on mike tyson's well
that's all
exactly yeah i mean that would be like i
don't see that i think so we got a song
here see he's gonna be bigger than this
music stuff because he got the vision
yeah of course we're just with uh me and
michael with the
arnold schwarzenegger yesterday that was
so awesome oh my man
damn icon
we know that you're going to be there
someday yeah yeah yeah man
give us some front row tickets for us
come on come on man this love is
bulletproof man i appreciate y'all
who come to your concert a lot of women
yeah yeah you do they write something
so they write yeah pictures they they
throw bras on stage and then there will
be notes written in the broads and phone
numbers and [ __ ] man there's one time
like the biggest broad ever seen man and
on one side there was one name the phone
number
on the other side it must have been her
homegirls
man it was fun
you saw them at you like yeah yeah gotta
be so low man
who's gonna hold this down he can't
handle
his breakdown no i'll probably don't do
that to her man why you love him
love love is a beautiful thing i [ __ ]
with love love can be war too
man it's hard work can you survive it
can you survive love it's a form of war
yes
yeah yeah but there's a lot of war yeah
right that's your war partner
i am is that your war partner what do
you think mike
love love his love of war partner yeah
it could you can ride you to the highest
highest points of the world on passion
motion
intellect and they can crush you to the
body can love manipulate you
no even that we want it to it doesn't do
it we allow it to
you're made out of love you can't help
it it's how much you let in
love isn't even awarded the white and
ward we have love because
the love knowing that you got my back
and know that he has
his you have his back and it's all from
love partnership yeah
even that brutal exactly love is what
we're made out of
everything's love you mean that thing
this is this is gandhi this is the dalai
lama this islam
this is what i found out from
experiences
his energy is just so that's not just
what i actually don't know
mike's making the comeback right mike
september i've never been nowhere i'm
just
doing nice things for nice people and in
the process mike you're you're uh
you know you're blessing a lot of people
man holy you know like you would
holyfield you guys are
you know i mean grateful i'm able to do
something imagine all that [ __ ] i've
been to all that [ __ ]
and i'm still doing this [ __ ] this is
what i'm 300
what the [ __ ] is going on with me yeah
300 am
what's going on that's me i come from
listen i came from being a cocaine
having [ __ ] um
ods and everything and next thing i did
the toe look at me i'm a [ __ ]
entrepreneur what the
[ __ ] happened shout out that time give
me a [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
well it's been an honor man today man i
can see the
i can see the next arnold right here
over here oh
my you know going into a legends house
yeah any last words
it's a privilege for me it's all about
the power of belief man
there's nothing in the world strong and
unconscious confidence breeds success
and success breeds confidence you know
confidence
applied appropriately yeah to super see
the genius
there's nothing more powerful than
confident
the game is just next level you and e40
are the two wisest most game-giving
individuals i don't know that's a real
tough pleasure of getting the crosstalk
that's that's that other part of the
world the consciousness regardless
in the belief yeah he tests you to see
if you really believe
yeah so you never get discouraged yeah
real talk i love it thank you
thank you for much love
that's it man we enjoyed having g easy
here i am your co-host triple c
and i'm mike tyson with the man g eazy
and the place to the best we ever did
and got away with it
you